[Music]
foreign
this is outnumbered I'm Harris Faulkner
here with my co-host Emily compagno and
Kaylee mcinini and joining us today oh
yeah Angel Earhart and Dr Mark Siegel
Dream Team yes I just we have to sit up
very straight on this year on the end my
mom would be so proud my posture's never
been better thanks all for having me Dr
Siegel I love you thank you for for
having me great to be on the couch with
you oh it's a wonderful to have you both
thank you all right well it is 15 days
until the midterm elections two weeks
from tomorrow yes we're counting and
there's a lot at stake particularly for
Democrats and President Biden right now
Democrats have very slim majorities in
Congress but crisis after crisis is
making the effort to cling to power all
the more difficult and now we are
getting some stunning new numbers
putting the surge of illegal immigrants
coming to our country into perspective
are we showing that well yeah so on one
side is the infrared that you can see
from the chopper over when you fly with
a DPS of Texas that's what you see there
in Eagle Pass
the last report from Customs and Border
Protection ahead of the midterms was
released on Friday night very quietly
you know we call it the classic bad news
dump on a Friday well after another
record breaker in September fiscal year
2022 made history with the highest
number of encounters nearly 2.4 million
not only that it was also the deadliest
year ever for those people trying to
come here
plus a total of 98 Terror suspects were
among those arrested at the border
so Ainsley what we see here is some
transparency we hope on the number of
Terror suspects right because that
number keeps growing and growing and
growing and then the other thing we see
here is that they're willing to play a
game of shells with us to kind of keep
the information out of a view over a
weekend well yes you're right Friday we
learn the news bill milugen was tweeting
about this they released the news he
found out about it because he went on
their website and saw the numbers there
was no press conference they want to
keep it hush-hush we all know Fridays if
you're anchoring a show Friday night you
don't have as many viewers typically
because people are off enjoying their
weekends and with their families so it's
interesting the timing of that the
second thing is the terrorists watch
list that's what's terrifying to me
because we all live through 9 11. how
many terrorist cells are already in our
country we know that they arrested 98
how many got through without us catching
them it only takes a handful of them to
to bring another 911 to all of us and
that is terrifying and it's just just
another example of how the Biden
Administration has failed us they are
allowing this to happen
you know Emily one of the things that we
talk about on this couch supporting law
enforcement border patrol the sheriffs
that are the backstop too and the
National Guard everybody all hands on
deck not enough of those people they're
outnumbered because of that open border
situation
and so one of my main concerns is now
you're asking them to do more with less
because what Ainsley's saying is the
godaways become an even more focused to
us now that we know that the number of
Terror suspects among them is greater
than what we've been told and has been
all along with each report and that
Mantra Harris is the Hallmark of the
Democrat Party and the bloated federal
government which is do more with less
while they absolutely ramp up and amp up
funding for everything off the charts of
our taxpayer dollars Ainsley hit the
nail on the head
the southern border and securing it to
me it's like washing your hands it's a
really basic fundamental premise it's a
fundamental notion that if you fail to
do it leads to a whole host of
calamities and the human body if you
don't wash your hands you are subjected
to a million kinds of illnesses like a
pandemic catastrophic pandemic
everything right and that's what the
southern border is to me so the fact
that this federal government fails to
secure it doesn't support doesn't
support law enforcement strains their
resources blames them shames them
publicly makes up lies dismantles their
units and then fails to acknowledge the
whole host of calamities coming across
the fentanyl issue that makes every
state a border state the terror watch
issue the disease issue the straining
the local resources issue the list goes
on and the hardest part for me to accept
as an American which I refuse to is that
the president of the United States won't
acknowledge those things it's like that
the New York crime issue we talked about
the other day where the mayor said well
it's all about perception and I said
well the perception needs to be that you
are acknowledging the Law and Order and
the crime issue so that I feel safe in
your hands them turning a blind eye to
all of these issues means I don't have
any faith in them at all well look
doctor part of the numbers that came
through or the the number of migrants
who are actually dying in all this and
when I was at the border just a few
weeks ago the border patrol agents their
hearts are just scratched over this
issue because they are pulling young
children families out of the Rio Grande
trying to resuscitate them but they
cannot be resuscitated to the to the
tune of 200 so far this year more than
700 pulled out of the water so they are
doing God's work and doctor's work to
bring back a few absolutely Harris and
as Emily just said the whole
dysfunctionality of the border is
leading to these massive health issues
that are going under-reported close to a
thousand deaths the sinola cartel the
Jalisco cartel using people pushing them
across the border their deaths of
overdoses but the number one cause of
death is trauma as you said drownings
people that are that are dehydration
accidents the hospitals down in the
southern border are overwhelmed I've
talked to the medical director McAllen
Hospital forget about it trauma number
one infectious diseases and the custom
and Border Protection people do not have
the ability at all the agents do not
have the ability at all to to take care
of infectious diseases or the trauma so
they're struggling to save people that
shouldn't be leaking across the border
in the first place and into our Southern
just real quickly because whenever we
talk like this blows up on the internet
and our critics say that we don't have a
heart for the people coming over which
is ridiculous when you stand down there
and you see the border patrol agents who
are willing to put themselves In Harm's
Way the one patrol officer that I'm
thinking of who drowned recently trying
to save people in the water when you see
that you know we're doing our level best
but I'll use this word again we're
outnumbered
and you know Harris you are absolutely
right and I'll add to that physicians Dr
Hodges who works down by El Paso watches
them coming across the border he runs a
clinic down there and he can't save
people and his heart goes out every day
a really caring doctor along with the
custom and Border Protection agents we
care about the people down there you
know we used to screen people when they
came into the United States
for a whole lot of things well at least
when I saw 354 come across the border I
didn't see anybody screen they were
screening them trying to process them
and get them away from the border so
they could take the next few Kaylee the
policies were were flipped like a switch
and now Biden's Administration and the
president are trying to maybe ease back
a little okay stay in Mexico
um you know they're trying to cherry
pick what they thought worked among
Trump's policies to get through November
8th yeah but people are smarter than
that I flew to Macallan Texas this
weekend I went to Weslaco Texas spoke at
a church Mid Valley assembly of about
five miles from the border I did a round
table there I listened to some business
owners I was there with Myra Flores who
of course the Latina who won that
District first Republican elected since
1871 Cassie Garcia whose husband is a
border patrol agent who's running
against Henry Cuellar these business
owners said to me this wasn't happening
under Trump to your point and not only
that for the first time you have the
Republican Party who's hitting this
message exactly as it should be hit
which is this we've got to have
compassion for the people crossing our
border 856 migrant deaths which by the
way we only know that number because of
Fox News exclusive reporting because
it's not released the tractor-trailer
deaths the the dozens of people who died
in that the mass drowning incident 13
who died kids being swept from their
mother's arms and these women who are
really dominating in the Republican
Party On the Border are hitting both
things and they should be hit because it
is a it is a absolute travesty when you
have 98 people on the terror watch list
that's more than the last five years
combined and then at the same time when
you have migrants who are dying in
rivers and you don't have a president
with enough compassion to look in a
camera and say do not come you are
risking your life well Kamala Harris did
it the vice president did it
back by the nape of her hair yes they
were like no take that back real quickly
congresswoman Maya Flores did you get to
talk with her a little bit about what
um the Hispanics and Latino families are
telling her in her area who came here
legally yes no she is saying that they
are on this issue that immigration is
important but one thing she did say to
me was this inflation's really important
she said she had a mother look at her
and say I had to take out a loan to buy
school supplies for my child so we've
got to remember South Texas in addition
to having this immigration crisis the
median income level is very low and the
economy is hitting there too yeah all
right we'll move on